all right boba fett he has a book he's
an author now we're going to talk about
it but first going to give some love to
the sponsor of this video this video is
brought to you by bespoke bespoke post
is a monthly membership club delivering
awesome boxes with a myriad of goods
your boxes are curated based on the quiz
you take with options and categories
like style accessories clothing music
and tech gear each box has 70 of retail
but you just pay a fraction of that and
each month before it ships you get a
preview of your box you can either keep
it swap it out for another box or just
skip that month entirely you won't get
charged at one point i got a package
aptly named the weekender it's perfect
for an overnight bad gory weekend bag i
mean i've carried vhs's in this bag it's
gotten a lot of use it's a well-made
sturdy bag this month i got the package
alchemy these ice cubes will be perfect
for the freezer fridge combo i have in
my nerd room also
party on dudes it's free to join so
click the link in the description go to
bespokepost.com jeremy20 enter promo
code jeremy20 upon checkout to get
yourself 20 off your first box and thank
you once again to bespoke post for
sponsoring this video i do appreciate it
all right now book of boba fett first of
all spoiler warning gonna talk about
spoilers for the book of boba fett i
don't want you to go in warned also i'm
gonna talk about a big spoiler in the
mandalorian season two if you know it
you know so that's my spoiler warning
you've been warned also not gonna be a
play-by-play just gonna talk about some
interesting things in the book of boba
fett that i liked some things i was like
those are power rangers so the book of
boba fett is a new series on disney plus
it's one that i didn't watch episode to
episode i just binged it and a pretty
great binge it was it first starts out
it shows how boba fett escaped the
sarlacc pit for a while now i've known
he's survived so i can't say someone was
boba fetted if they were just cheaply
killed i say washed now till they wreck
on that
hopefully but it shows how he escaped
the sarlacc pit what he was doing
afterwards it's really two stories
you're following two stories here one is
boba fett and fenik shand his
partner in not crime his partner in
anti-crime they've taken over jabba's
crime syndicate from bib fortuna they're
like all right we got to establish
ourselves as the new boss we gotta rule
with respect not necessarily fear so
you're seeing that and then when boba
fett sleeps in his bathtu tank so he can
heal from all the sarlacc pit damage
that he took you see flashbacks of what
he was doing leading up to this point
for the past few years where he was
hanging out with tusk and raiders and
for a while here i was like the tuscan
raiders storyline that's clearly the
more interesting of the two arcs it did
a lot for tuscan raiders for me showed a
lot of their traditions how their tribe
works it's that whole storyline that
you've seen before but it's cool seeing
boba fett do it with tuscan raiders
where it's like he's a prisoner and then
he becomes a member of the tribe
eventually it got me to care because
dude in star wars galaxies we're talking
old school star wars galaxies those of
you who remember remember og star wars
galaxies tuscan raiders were difficult
they were business they had red life
bars but they shouldn't be easy they
should be tough that's their territory
tatooine is their territory they're like
the oldest settlers on tatooine i was
glad that this showed why they're
actually badass you see where gaffy
sticks come from
i dug that i like i dig that kind of
stuff when you expand the lore of a
culture that i just kind of took for
granted like oh yeah they're vicious
mindless monsters and of course they had
to do a train job this train just comes
through just starts popping shots that
these tuscans takes them out and so boba
fett's like i'll train you how to take
out that train which i love a train job
when in doubt have a train job a train
job is easily the second greatest kind
of job you can get in life but when they
were doing the train job the tuscans
start getting popped off and killed and
i was like oh man you're gonna have to
go back and explain why they died and
they died and it was your plan that's
probably gonna weigh heavy on you the
fact that i cared that much showed how
much this show got me to care about the
task and it also made me appreciate boba
fett's armor like i like og boba fett's
armor the most in this one he had the
black robe with the armor i was like
okay it looks a bit too clean but really
it's his tuscan robe when he becomes
part of that tribe with his boba fett
armor with his bounty hunter armor it
really is boba fett wearing his life i
just i don't know made me appreciate it
more then that tuscan tribe gets killed
off screen because that's how star wars
does it there were some great characters
in this show like badass wookie
i thought he was the best like of the
characters i want to see more of i'm
glad they have them in here i'm glad
they didn't die and i thought they were
going to die but they didn't die bad as
wookies at the top of the list not
everything worked matt because internet
is kind of funny internet chatter is
just it goes everywhere and you hear
about it whether you even look for it or
not the power rangers that aren't power
is they're not really it's not like the
power rangers are in the book of boba
fett but there's this crew this group
you totally think of the power rangers i
saw internet talking about that i was
like it's not gonna really feel like it
when you watch it holy [ __ ] they're the
power rangers power rangers jokes aside
you know my thing with them is they
didn't they felt out of place in the
book of boba fett let alone tatooine
they didn't feel like they fit in star
wars i felt like they would have fit in
star wars in that weird gambling planet
in episode 8
the last jedi
i forgot the title for a second wow my
brain is really working overtime
thank you brain oh god canto bite now i
remember the name of the planet damn it
brian let's go back we got to go back to
when i was forgetting that stuff it
wouldn't have felt so out of place there
but on tatooine when you're part of boba
fett's plan for the big the big push you
know it's like okay we have our army
it's like a warhammer setup it's like
everyone's set up and that army's set up
and okay we're making our big move and
part of the plan is be inconspicuous and
just kind of lay low you can't ride
around with these flashy ass bright
colored bikes you stand out everyone's
like what's up with those bikes they
kind of they seem out of place in this
[ __ ] hole why what are they doing well
if it should have been like you paint
your bikes you burn them or you get
other bikes you get different bikes and
i can't help but feel like they felt
like cyborg hipsters from earth the year
3047. that wouldn't have been too
surprised if at the end they were like
oh wow glad we got to help you all here
in this galaxy far far away yeah we're
from a different time we're from the
future in another galaxy called the
milky way earth the year 3047 but now we
have to go our planet needs us
just wouldn't have been too surprised
between the neutrinos and the wookie
the wookie does win then after about
four episodes of the book of boba fett
it becomes the mandalorian season 2.5 we
catch up with mando which not gonna lie
some really cool stuff in those episodes
they could have just brought the
mandalorian back in and then the
mandalorian season three or whatever
they're going to do they could have been
like all right now we're going to go
back and show how
uh mando got grogo again and then you
see the flashback and that's when he
hangs out with luke and all that but
then the very logical decision which i
think is the right call is like dude
fans want to see luke
we gotta have luke in the book of boba
fett also luke looks so much better in
this season than he did the mandalorian
season two i believe that that's the
legend this is the legend here story is
the mandalorian season two happened you
see luke luke had cgi face you could
tell it was cgi face and then dude on
youtube was like i can do better than
that and then he did luke but it was
better and then lucasfilm was straight
up like deadpool like
you're in and they hired him which is
great i love that kind of team playing i
mean some video game companies out there
they're not so nice i'm aiming this one
at nintendo nintendo would have been
like here's a cease and desist you will
pull that from the internet thank you no
one shatters her ego like that it's am2r
i'm just salty what can i say so i like
the fact that they're like we want the
best on our team and if that person's
the best they're on the team but it does
show luke looks so much better this
season it's neat seeing luke as this
young badass jedi
master who's training a new jedi you
know the building is temple which might
very well be the temple from episode
seven flashbacks that gets burned down
by kylo ren but i feel like you know
jedi temple and the thought of it
burning down like that's that's the
reason we have mando in this season jedi
temple sacking is the reason for the
season because it might seem kind of
strange that mando worked for two years
well two seasons anyway to get grogu to
a jedi and he succeeded and now grogu is
just back with mando like it never
happened it's possible they were like
all right sweet baby grogu is with luke
we have succeeded so does that mean
groggy dies when kylo ren sacks the
temple
[ __ ]
okay here we go couple episodes of book
above a fat baby girl goo goes back with
mando can't just have him die off screen
like other characters that works for
owen and beru also works for an entire
tribe of tuscans but not kroger he
fashions him a piece of methyl armor
from lord of the rings fellowship of the
ring and then luke's like okay grogu you
have a choice you can take the armor
either mandalorian armor or you can take
master yoda's lightsaber which [ __ ]
knows how i got this thing
because that was lost in the fight with
the emperor i don't know how luke got
that star wars for having all the story
lines and backstories for all the
weapons except how people find
lightsabers how luke found yoda's
lightsaber amaz kanata found luke's
lightsaber that was lost in the pit of
[ __ ] knows what and goes where knows who
in the cloud city i just how do they get
these lightsabers back but i digress
point is grogu has a choice does he take
the armor that mando made for him or the
lightsaber that was yoda's i know what i
thought i was like well mando's flying a
naboo starfighter that's completely
modded like a [ __ ] it looks so
cool nabu starfighter's always been a
cool ship very sleek very royal but now
he's like yeah but it's also it's
mandalified also where the astromech
droid usually sits is this really
convenient space for baby grogu to just
sit and pal around with mando on his
adventures pretty sure he's going back
with mando now grog who's back with
mando gonna be real the whole big hug he
gives him the repair man you can't you
can't split the band up like that i do
like weird little details in the show
too like when mando was wielding the
darksaber and he's doing that fight with
shovel knight the darksaber's getting
heavier which is very old-school star
wars if you look at obi-wan and darth
vader fighting and lucas was talking
about how they had to grab the
lightsabers with both hands because it's
basically like
they have to harness this energy and it
takes a lot of willpower to do that
later episodes like yeah we're
single-handed wielding it it's fine it's
no big deal but i like the concept that
you have to wield it with two hands it's
just like this raw energy i feel like
the dark saber was doing that it was
really cool a neat scene also when
grosgu's training with luke is when luke
helps him remember and you see grogu in
what looks like the jedi temple order 66
is happening and jedi are just getting
wiped out around him because i like
anything order 66 man it's such a sweet
moment in the star wars mythos i'll be
honest
i had my fingers crossed one could call
it a prayer that a hooded figure with a
blue lightsaber would plop down and
start slashing up jedi and grogu's
memory
that would have been really sweet
it would have been pretty badass come on
i didn't need it you know it's fine
stormtroopers did a lot of the killing
too
just saying but talking about badass mvp
character of the book of boba fett dude
cad bane brought so much to the show the
moment he shows up it becomes this
amazing western
meet star wars this vibe that i
dig about tatooine there's something
about tatooine i've always loved when i
played old school star wars galaxies
before the patches when it was the
hardcore star wars grind i just stayed
on tatooine i never left i went off
world to naboo i was it just feels out
of place i was a bounty hunter on
tattooing something's about the place
the grit the atmosphere i dig it and cad
bane fit into this show perfectly the
way he talks the way he carries himself
i was like this is a character i hope
they don't kill
don't kill him you have so much you can
do with him and they
the boba fett kills him i guess
apparently it's sci-fi he could come
back but in that standoff with cad bane
i did like how boba fett takes him down
you know it's the gaffy stick and he
trips him up and he stabs him with it it
just kind of shows that boba fett's new
life that he's annexed into his style
that's what took out cad bane you know
there's something poetic about that when
he stabbed him i was like
he might still be okay i'm hoping i'm
hoping cad bane lived through it granted
he's with clone wars so i mean if you
want to see more cad bane it's out there
but damn if he wasn't the coolest
addition to the show i mean the climax
the finale the last episode of booker
boba fett that was no joke big old
battle droids with shields i was like
just walk through the shields because
battle draws oh it illustrates that
that's really hard to do i guess the
battle droids have some sort of thing
that helps them absorb the energy well
then you're right you might be [ __ ]
sorry thanks for playing but then boba
fett comes in riding the rancor like
he's in the courtship of princess leia
or some [ __ ] man how rad was that like
you know just like cool things happened
in the book above effect big old
rancours smashing up these big battle
droids how could i not watch that with a
big smile on my face there's no way you
know i just i liked it guys in the end
the book of boba fett i had a really
good time with it it's one of those
shows that i'm glad i binged just in
terms of my enjoyment i found what i
think is the optimal enjoyment for the
show in a binge for me i mean
logistically algorithmically in terms of
youtube hits because this past january
was more january than most januaries do
my channel was like
content
right so this part of me is like i could
have gone for episode episode but in
terms of my optimal enjoyment of the
show
looking at the episodes i probably would
have been like oh you know i was just
hanging out with the tuscans more and i
wish more would happen because i'm not a
patient person it's one of my flaws and
one of my strengths because your
strengths are your weaknesses and your
weaknesses are your strengths just in
certain situations you got to know
yourself i know me and a binge of book
of boba fett is the optimum way i was
going to enjoy it i actually really
enjoyed it it did a lot for me boba
fett's got respect as a leader grogu and
mando are out there on their adventures
you know one of my favorite things about
this whole thing really doesn't have to
do with boba fett and the book of boba
fett besides cad bane is the fact that
luke and ahsoka are hanging out ahsoka
is hanging out with her former master's
son now on the other side of it luke is
hanging out with his father's former
apprentice so they're both getting that
closure they're both having those
conversations that i
had in my own
fan head cannon but i saw that ahsoka
and luke were both
in these shows in mandalorian season two
i was like oh the potential of
conversation we don't see the
conversations and that kind of
resolution between the two characters
happening on screen other than ahsoka
makes a comment about how she's a long
time friend of the family which i
thought was a really cool line to have
but you know those moments are happening
every night having tea like so tell me
about my father ahsoka's getting piece
of oh i'm glad he died good now we don't
get to see it happen here doesn't mean
we won't see it in the future but even
if we don't see it in the future you
know the conversations are happening and
that's enough for me i'm glad those two
characters met up you know what i really
hope though like i i really hope
cat bane is not dead
i'll stop all right so the book of boba
fett have you seen it what did you think
about it did you like it did you watch
it episode the episode did you binge it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you